This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人带着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，倾听并学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
通过AHA电台应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听“艰难成长的教训”。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控使人生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。互联网侦探大军花了很长时间才揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《受困之爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例是2%。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he does. He's going to get what he
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取自主行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的。他会得到
deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. Today's episode was inspired by a listener who emailed me a few weeks back with a conundrum. And I'm going to start the episode by reading what they said. Hi, Gemma. I have a more rare but personal episode request that I would love for you to consider. Basically, my situation is that it feels like I've spent my whole life daydreaming about a better
应得的。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在Iheart radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜们：相信我，宝贝》。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析你二十几岁的心理。今天的节目灵感来源于几周前给我发电子邮件提出一个难题的一位听众。我将通过朗读他们的话来开始这期节目。嗨，杰玛（Gemma）。我有一个比较罕见但很私人的节目请求，希望你能考虑一下。基本上，我的情况是，感觉我的一生都在幻想一个更好的
life rather than just living the one I have. I can get lost in these big dreams whilst I'm still awake, minutes passing by without me even realizing. I've created imaginary friends, imaginary enemies, pets, careers, scenarios, and I play them over and over again. Anytime I get the chance, I daydream. And it's getting to the point where I've lost too many hours in my life to count, probably more than four hours a day. What can you tell me about this? And am I the only one? As soon as I read this email, I knew I had to do an episode on maladaptive daydreaming.
生活，而不是去过我真正拥有的生活。我会在清醒的时候迷失在这些宏大的梦想中，几分钟就这样流逝，甚至毫无察觉。我创造了想象中的朋友、想象中的敌人、宠物、职业、各种情景，我一遍又一遍地把它们演练出来。只要有机会，我就会白日做梦。这已经到了让我浪费了无数时间的程度，可能一天超过四个小时。你能告诉我关于这个的什么信息？我是唯一一个这样的人吗？一读到这封电子邮件，我就知道我必须做一期关于适应不良性白日梦的节目。
Because this listener is by no means alone. There are thousands, millions of people going through the same thing, finding comfort in their imagination and their daydreams that, you know, they can't find that comfort in the real world, spending hours thinking about their dream life and picturing it so intensely, but also struggling to make real life progress towards it or to be fully present in their day-to-day existence. I don't think it's surprising to say that this has become a lot more common, especially for people in their 20s, because of how uncertain this decade is, how uncertain the world is.
因为这位听众绝不是孤单一人。有成千上万、数以百万计的人正在经历同样的事情，在他们的想象和白日梦中寻求慰藉，而你知道，他们在现实世界中找不到这种慰藉，花上几个小时思考他们的梦想生活并生动地描绘它，但同时也难以在现实生活中取得进展或完全活在当下的日常生活中。我认为可以说这变得越来越普遍，特别是对于二十几岁的人来说，这并不令人意外，因为这十年充满了不确定性，这个世界充满了不确定性。
daydreaming offers a temporary release from the stress and from the choice overload and from the confusion. As we'll get into, you know, the more lost, confused, anxious, disappointed, heartbroken maybe you feel, the more likely you are to daydream. And it's no surprise that this is common amongst this generation because we are so overwhelmed by getting it right. We are facing such intense pressure to be exceptional. Everything just feels so much harder for our age group as well. You know, who doesn't want to feel like they have an escape? And we all find a way to escape somehow through drinking, through, I don't know, maybe drugs, through addiction. And daydreaming is also one of those ways. So let's talk our way through why that
白日梦提供了一种暂时的释放，让人从压力、选择过载和困惑中解脱出来。正如我们将要探讨的，你知道，你感到越迷茫、越困惑、越焦虑、越失望、也许越心碎，你就越有可能做白日梦。毫无疑问，这代人普遍存在这种情况，因为我们太纠结于“做正确的事”了。我们面临着要做到卓越的巨大压力。对我们这个年龄段的人来说，一切都感觉难得多。你知道，谁不想感觉自己有条出路呢？我们都通过某种方式找到出路——通过喝酒、通过，我不知道，可能是通过药物、通过成瘾。而白日梦也是其中一种方式。所以让我们来探讨一下为什么会这样。
is. What are the basics of maladaptive daydreaming that you should probably know, but maybe don't? How does it differ from just having a really immersive creative imagination or being a visual thing? and what are the signs to look out for? I also want to talk about the link between loneliness, trauma, OCD, anxiety, because daydreaming is actually a lot more complex than we think. There is this whole cycle that can explain what draws people into maladaptive daydreaming as a coping mechanism, but because it is such a private experience, it's so hard to actually get answers and to talk about it openly,
适应不良性白日梦的基本知识是什么？你可能应该知道，但也许并不知道？它与单纯具有真正沉浸式的创造力想象力或视觉化有什么不同？有哪些需要注意的迹象？我还想讨论孤独、创伤、强迫症（OCD）、焦虑之间的联系，因为白日梦实际上比我们想象的要复杂得多。存在着一个完整的循环，可以解释是什么吸引人们陷入适应不良性白日梦作为一种应对机制，但由于这是一种极其私人的体验，因此很难真正得到答案并公开讨论它，
and it's not really part of the discussion. But of course, it really should be. I also want to talk about a really interesting theory that I came across that explains how we actually can turn daydreaming into a method to motivate and energize ourselves rather than as this form of escapism, how we can shift our imagination towards intentional visualization. When I came across this theory, I was like, this is incredible, this is remarkable. It's like scientific manifestation. It's wonderful. So I really hope that you take something away from this episode. I hope you learn something about yourself.
而且它并没有真正成为讨论的一部分。但当然，它确实应该成为一部分。我还想讨论一个我偶然发现的非常有趣的理论，它解释了我们实际上如何将白日梦变成一种激励和激发我们自身的方法，而不是将其作为一种逃避现实的形式，我们如何将想象力转向有意的视觉化。当我偶然发现这个理论时，我想：这太不可思议了，这太卓越了。这就像是科学化的显化。太棒了。所以我真的希望你能从这期节目中有所收获。我希望你能了解一些关于你自己的事情。
I hope you learned something about how to be a more kind of like powerful cognitive and mental being, taking that daydreaming element that sometimes can be so negative and turning it into something really positive. So I'm going to stop rambling. Without further ado, let's get into the psychology of maladaptive daydreaming. If you want to know whether you have to be able to do, if you want to know whether you have a problem with maladaptive daydreaming, it is probably firstly best to know what it is and what distinguishes it from kind of aimlessly losing track of your thoughts from time to time.
我希望你能学到一些关于如何成为一个更强大、更有认知和心理能力的人，把有时会带来巨大负面影响的白日梦元素转化为真正积极的东西。所以我要停止唠叨了。废话不多说，让我们进入适应不良性白日梦的心理学。如果你想知道自己是否必须能够做到，如果你想知道自己是否有适应不良性白日梦的问题，可能首先最好了解它是什么，以及它与那种偶尔漫无目的地失去思绪的情况有什么区别。
Well, maladaptive daydreaming occurs when we spend a lot of our time during our days, weeks and months, daydreaming about the past, the future, making up these really vivid and complex plots that completely engulf us. The key word here, is maladaptive. There is such a thing as healthy daydreaming. You know, some people would call it immersive daydreaming where we zone out for a few minutes here and there. Our brain kind of switches off and we get to like pop into our warm, gooey imagination. That is totally healthy. It's totally normal. It's part of how our brain works. But the distinction is that those instances are quite brief and they're often something that we can control. It is not as well where we spend most
好吧，适应不良性白日梦发生在我们将白天、每周和每月的大量时间都花在幻想过去、未来，编造那些完全吞噬我们的生动而复杂的剧情时。这里的关键词是“适应不良”。存在健康的白日梦这回事。你知道，有些人称之为沉浸式白日梦，我们在某些地方会走神几分钟。我们的大脑有点关闭了，我们得以进入我们温暖、融化的想象力中。这是完全健康的。这是完全正常的。这是我们大脑工作方式的一部分。但区别在于，这些情况相当短暂，而且通常是我们能够控制的。它也不是我们花费大部分时间的地方
of our days. So there are a few components that really make maladaptive daydreaming stand out and they put it in a league of its own. First of all, it interrupts your daily life and it pulls you away from everyday activities. You know, you could be doing your dishes and then suddenly you are like absorbed by a daydream for like 10, 20 minutes or even longer before you like come back down to earth and you're like, wait, 20 minutes has passed and I'm still kind of just aimlessly standing at the sink. The daydreaming also almost feels preferable to your real life. It's addictive in a way. So it pulls you back in again and again and again. Some people have actually described to me as almost being like a hobby. It's something that they prioritize, that they're like, you know, I'm not
的日子里。因此，有几个成分真正让适应不良性白日梦脱颖而出，使其自成一派。首先，它会打断你的日常生活，把你从日常活动中拉开。你知道，你可能正在洗碗，然后突然间你被白日梦吸引了10、20分钟甚至更长时间，直到你回过头来脚踏实地，心想：等等，20分钟过去了，我怎么还在水槽边漫无目的地站着。白日梦甚至感觉比你的现实生活更讨人喜欢。从某种意义上说它是令人上瘾的。所以它一遍又一遍地把你拉回去。有些人甚至向我形容这几乎就像是一种爱好。这是他们优先考虑的事情，他们会想：“你知道的，我不
going to go see my friends. I'm going to deliberately stay up later. I'm not going to get up from the couch because I just kind of want to sit here and daydream. I want to sit here and fantasize. Like that's something that I plan for. The daydreams, as I said before, are often really vivid and compelling. It is like a whole almost movie series is happening in your brain. There are characters, there are plot lines, multiple plot lines, there are different settings that you could almost describe in detail. It's such a personal private experience that it's really hard to get specific examples of what this looks like. But some people have really reported creating entire lives in their imagination where they run multiple successful businesses. They have homes in three states.
打算去见朋友了。我要故意熬夜。我不想从沙发上起来，因为我只想坐在里边做白日梦。我想坐在这里幻想。”就像那是我有计划要做的事。正如我之前所说，白日梦通常非常生动和引人入胜。这就像你的大脑里正在上演一整部几乎是电影系列的剧集。里面有角色，有情节线，多条情节线，有不同的场景，你几乎可以用细节来描述。这是一种非常个人化、私密的体验，很难给出这到底是什么样子的具体例子。但有些人确实报告说，他们在想象中创造了整个人生，经营着多项成功的企业。他们在三个州拥有房产。
They can describe the love of their life that they have in their imagination. Then they can almost go into these subplots. Like they could tell you when they met that partner, what's inside their homes, what these homes look like because they spend so much time building out. this world. Some people also, you know, they daydream about all the ways they could go back and change something in the past. They may also think about what it would be like to be famous, what it would be like to do something really heroic and they have this like one instance that they replay. Very intimate moments with a partner, shared adventures with a partner, what it would be like to have someone like that. You know, you could tell me almost like the smells, the sensations, the sounds
他们可以描述他们想象中一生的挚爱。然后他们几乎可以深入到这些次要情节中。比如他们可以告诉你他们是什么时候遇到那个伴侣的，他们的家里有什么，这些房子长什么样，因为他们花了太多时间来构建这个世界。有些人还会，你知道，他们会幻想所有他们可以回到过去改变某些事情的方法。他们也可能会想象出名是什么感觉，做一些非常英雄主义的事情是什么感觉，并且他们会反复重温这唯一的一个情境。与伴侣非常亲密的时刻，与伴侣共同的冒险，拥有那样的人会是什么感觉。你知道，你可以几乎像告诉我气味、感觉、声音一样
of what this feels like and all the while you could be sitting in front of me and have this entirely different world playing out in your head. If you are actually someone who experience this, I really want to hear from you because it sounds so intriguing, like all the reports that I was receiving and all the different case studies that I read and the people that I heard of, it was completely different for basically every single person. So please DM me if you have stories.
这种感觉是什么样的，与此同时，你可能正坐在我面前，脑海中却在上演着这个完全不同的世界。如果你真的是一个经历过这种状况的人，我真的很想听到你的心声，因为这听听就觉得非常引人入胜，就像我收到的所有报告、我读过的一切不同案例研究以及我听说过的人一样，对几乎每一个人来说都是完全不同的。所以如果你有关于这方面的故事，或者它对你来说切换到适应不良性白日梦状态是什么感觉，请私信我。
about this or what it feels like for you to kind of switch into your maladaptive daydreaming state. It's because of this very aspect, actually, how amazing it feels and how personal and private and intimate, how specific an individual it is, that it can be really easy to form an emotional attachment to our daydreams, even having like our favorites that we repeat over and over again, like a favorite movie. With time, though, we kind of realize that. that they aren't true. They may never be true. And because of how invested we've become, we feel really, really disappointed. We feel crushed. We also start to feel like, we have wasted all of this time, as that person said at the beginning, that we could have spent
正是因为这方面的特征，实际上——它感觉多么奇妙，多么个人化、私密和亲密，它是多么具体和个性化——人们很容易对白日梦产生情感依恋，甚至有我们一遍又一遍重复的最爱，就像最喜欢的电影一样。然而，随着时间的推移，我们开始意识到它们不是真实的。它们可能永远都不会成为现实。正因为我们投入了如此多的精力，我们感到非常非常失望。我们感到心碎。我们还开始觉得，我们浪费了所有这些时间，就像开头那个人说的那样，而这些时间本可以用来
creating that reality. We've wasted all this time that we could have spent being present, doing something about our dreams. But instead, we have been stuck in this thought loop. nothing has come from it that time feels wasted even though it felt so nice things are still the same and that can make us really stressed and really desperate to find a way to stop to just be present to make our reality be just as good even if like specifically we don't know how and that is the curse of maladaptive daydreaming it's like here is our brain and it's going to serve us up something that is so delicious and desirable and believable and perfect for us that we forget it's not real.
创造那个现实。我们浪费了所有本可以用来活在当下、为我们的梦想做点什么的时间。但相反，我们却陷入了这个思维循环中。结果什么也没有产生，那些时间感觉被浪费了，尽管它感觉那么美好，但一切都还是老样子，这会让我们感到压力巨大，极其渴望找到一种方法停下来，仅仅是活在当下，让我们的现实也变得同样美好，即使我们具体不知道该怎么做，这就是适应不良性白日梦的诅咒。它就像是我们的大脑，它会给我们端上一盘如此美味、令人向往、可信且对我们而言完美的食物，以至于我们忘记了这不是真的。
And then when we do, there is this very long fall back to reality. It's something quite a few people report like a daydreaming hangover or daydreaming guilt. Kind of like when you, you know, you wake up from a really good dream and you try to like fall back asleep or you try to like relive it as soon as you wake up but you know eventually it just feels like it's moving further and further away i remember being like 20 and i had this like amazing dream about being on holiday in greece and i met this man and this amazing guy and in my dream we had this like crazy whirlwind romance and we fell in love and it felt so amazing and then we were and then i woke up my god did you just see how i said we look yeah i was i was i was
然后当我们意识到时，就会经历非常漫长地跌回现实的过程。有些人的反应相当奇特，就像是“白日梦宿醉”或“白日梦内疚”。有点像当你，你知道，你从一个极好的美梦中醒来，然后你试着再次入睡，或者你试着在你一醒来时就去重温它，但你知道最终它只是感觉离你越来越远。我记得我20岁的时候，做了一个神奇的梦，梦见自己在希腊度假，我遇到了这个男人，这个了不起的家伙，在我的梦里，我们有了一场疯狂的旋风般的浪漫，我们坠入爱河，感觉太美妙了，然后我们——然后我醒了，天哪，你刚看到我是怎么说我们看的吗？是的，我当时我当时我当时
woke up. He's not real. And it wasn't real. And the aftermath, though, of trying to hold on to how real it did feel and longing and the sadness, that is a dream hangover. And I cannot imagine feeling like that all the time from a daydream. So hopefully you kind of get the picture. It's a lot more complex than just, you know, occasionally zoning out. But now for, you know, more clinical perspective, some of the science attached to why this kind of happens. You know, researchers used to think that it was a type of like dissociative disorder where there was like a loss of connection between who we are, our thoughts, our feelings and our surroundings and this pattern of, I don't know, fantasy that was happening in our brain. There's also been like a real push actually
醒了。他不是真的。那不是真的。然而，在试图抓住那种真实感时的余波、渴望和悲伤，那就是一场白日梦宿醉。我无法想象自己总是因为一个白日梦而有这种感觉。所以希望你能大概理解这个画面了。这比单纯地，你知道，偶尔走神要复杂得多。但现在，为了从，你知道，更临床的角度来看，一些与为什么会发生这种现象有关的科学。你知道，研究人员过去认为这是一种解离性障碍，即我们的身份、思想、感觉和周围环境之间失去了联系，以及这种发生在我们大脑中的，我不知道，幻想模式。其实近年来也有真正的推动力
in recent years and it was just in the news last week to get maladaptive data. dreaming listed as its own mental health disorder in the DSM. Mainly because people like, well, this is just so complex and destructive, we need really great minds on this. I need a diagnosis. But of course, if you know like the clinical psychology community in the DSM, it is so hard to get new disorders considered. So as of right now, maladaptive daydreaming is not a mental health disorder. It's still seen as quite rare or niche. But most people, professionals would actually say that that's because maladaptive daydreaming isn't so much a condition. It's a coping strategy. So it is not the root of our so-called problem. It is a symptom of that.
并在上周的新闻中被提及，即希望将适应不良性白日梦作为一种独立的精神健康障碍列入《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）。主要是因为人们觉得，好吧，这太复杂且具有破坏性了，我们需要非常聪明的人来研究这个。我需要一个诊断。但当然，如果你了解临床心理学界和DSM，就会知道要让新的精神障碍被审议是多么困难。所以截至目前，适应不良性白日梦并不是一种精神健康障碍。它仍然被视为相当罕见或小众。但大多数专业人士实际上会说，这是因为适应不良性白日梦与其说是一种病情，不如说是一种应对策略。所以它不是我们所谓问题的根源。它是其中的一个症状。
And it comes as a result of things like loneliness, trauma, general depression. It's a product of those previous experiences. But because it's seen as a symptom rather than as the origin or a condition, it actually means that no one is systematically measuring the prevalence in society. There is not many people doing in-depth research. There is a group that is very dedicated to this. And I did find some studies from them over the past two years that really wanted to look at the prevalence of maladaptive daydreaming. So there was one study in 2022 that said about 2.5% of people experience this. there was a 2021 study that said 34.3% of their participants identified as being maladaptive daydreamers.
它是孤独、创伤、普遍抑郁等事物共同作用的结果。它是那些先前经历的产物。但因为它被视为一种症状而不是起源或病情，这实际上意味着没有人系统地在衡量它在社会中的流行程度。没有多少人在做深入研究。有一个非常致力于此的群体。我在过去两年里确实发现了一些来自他们的研究，他们真的很想研究适应不良性白日梦的流行程度。因此，2022年有一项研究表明，大约有2.5%的人经历过这种情况。还有一项2021年的研究表明，34.3%的参与者被认定为患有适应不良性白日梦。
I'm just going to caveat that and say that's really quite high. That was a group of university students though and as we know it is more common in younger population groups but still 35%. You know, just that's mind blowing. The most trusted source in my mind though for how many people are experiencing this came from a study that observed around 3,000 American adults, and it concluded that about 4% of us would meet the clinical cutoff for maladaptive daydreaming. That's about 1 in 25, which I think is quite believable. Now, when we say clinical cutoff, what they're really referring to is actually this measure of whether you are a maladaptive daydreamer or not. And it is called the 16-item, Maladaptive Daydreaming
我在这里加个前提，说这其实相当高。不过那是一群大学生，正如我们所知，它在年轻人群体中更为常见，但仍然有35%。你知道，这简直令人大开眼界。然而在我心中，关于到底有多少人在经历这种情况的最权威来源，来自于一项对大约3000名美国成年人进行观察的研究，该研究得出结论：我们当中约有4%的人达到了适应不良性白日梦的临床临界值。这大约是每25人中有1人，我认为这相当可信。现在，当我们说临床临界值时，他们真正指的是对你是否是适应不良性白日梦患者的这种衡量标准。它被称为16项适应不良性白日梦
Scale. Super simple. name. There are 16 questions. Something that had me shocked, though, have a guess when it was developed. So maladaptive daydreaming has been around for years and years and years centuries. Only eight years ago. Eight years ago was when they had the first screening tool implemented that could tell, they could kind of, I don't know, not diagnose, but had a clinical cutoff for what we could count as maladaptive daydreaming. That's like yesterday in my mind. Like only eight years ago, 2016. That's wild. So there are 16 questions on this list. Some of them include like when you know that you have something important or challenging to pay attention to or finish,
量表。超级简单的名字。有16个问题。然而有一件事让我震惊，猜猜它是什么时候开发的。所以适应不良性白日梦已经存在了多年又多年，几个世纪了。就在八年前。就在八年前，他们才实施了第一个能够判断的筛查工具，它们可以某种程度上，我不知道，不是诊断，但对我们能算作适应不良性白日梦的情况设定了一个临床临界值。这在我看来就像是昨天的事。就像仅仅在八年前，2016年。这太疯狂了。所以这个列表上有16个问题。其中一些包括：当你明知自己有重要或具挑战性的事情需要注意或完成时，
how difficult was it for you to stay on task and complete the goal without daydreaming? Another question, when the real world interrupts one of your daydreams, how annoyed do you feel? How much does your daydreaming interfere with your academic or occupational success? To what extent is your daydreaming dependent on listening to music? These are just some examples. I'll leave a full link to the measure. It's actually publicly accessible. I'll leave it below.
你在不陷入白日梦的情况下保持专注并完成目标的难度有多大？另一个问题是，当现实世界打断你的某个白日梦时，你感到多么恼火？你的白日梦在多大程度上干扰了你的学业或职业成功？你的白日梦在多大程度上依赖于听音乐？这些只是一些例子。我会留下该评估工具的完整链接。它其实是公开访问的。我把它留在下面。
Just a quick reminder. If you're going to go and look at it with all self-reporting scores, try and be honest. Score yourself accurately. And just remember that it's not the only confirmation. You know, it is important to talk to a professional, but it's an interesting resource. definitely something really, really fascinating.
只是一个简单的提醒。如果你打算去查看它以及所有自我报告的分数，请尽量诚实。准确地为自己打分。并请记住，这不是唯一的确认方式。你知道，与专业人士交谈很重要，但它是一个有趣的资源。绝对是非常、非常引人入胜的。
The individuals who actually developed this scale, they make up a group called the International Consortium. Do I am I saying that right? Is it International Concertorium for Maladaptive Daydreaming Research? This is an entire body of researchers and psychologists who are primarily interested in why we get so wrapped up in these fantasies. And they've had a lot of really cool discoveries over recent years. What was really fascinating was one of their recent papers that found people who are maladaptive
实际开发这个量表的个人组成了一个名为国际联盟（International Consortium）的群体。我是不是说对了？是国际适应不良性白日梦研究协会（International Consortium for Maladaptive Daydreaming Research）吗？这是一个由研究人员和心理学家组成的整个机构，他们主要对我们为什么会如此沉迷于这些幻想感兴趣。近年来，他们有很多非常酷的发现。真正引人入胜的是他们最近的一篇论文，该论文发现成年后的适应不良性
daydreamers as adults were often very creative children. They often had make-believe imaginary friends. They were more likely to be scolded for daydreaming in class when they were younger. So that kind of pattern of creativity and imagination follows us into adulthood. but also, and maybe less pleasant, there is a really known relationship between adverse childhood experiences and becoming a maladaptive daydreamer. So when your circumstances as a child are very bleak and hard and stressful and you don't have the autonomy or the independence to leave to walk away, you find a private internal escape.
白日梦患者在小时候通常是非常有创造力的孩子。他们经常有虚构的想象朋友。他们年轻时在课堂上因为白日梦而受到责骂的可能性更高。因此，这种创造力和想象力的模式一直伴随着我们进入成年。但同样，也许没那么令人愉快，童年逆境经历与成为适应不良性白日梦患者之间存在着广为人知的关系。因此，当你童年时的环境非常凄凉、艰难、充满压力，并且你没有自主权或独立性离开、走开时，你会寻找一个私人的内在逃生出口。
And that sanctuary is often your mind and your thoughts and your dreams. I actually used to work in this space. I don't know if I've spoken about this much on the show, but before I started the podcast, I would interview people about child maltreatment and child abuse. And one of the biggest misconceptions is that adverse childhood experiences only refer to abuse or neglect or physical violence. But if you also include being a child in an angry household
而这个避难所通常就是你的心灵、你的思想和你的梦想。我实际上过去就在这个领域工作过。我不知道我是否在节目中多谈过这一点，但在我开始做播客之前，我会采访关于虐待儿童和儿童虐待的人。最大的误解之一是，童年逆境经历仅指虐待、忽视或身体暴力。但如果你把身为一个生活在愤怒家庭中的儿童也算进去，
or being a child with absent parents who worked a lot, being a child in a house with a lot of conflict and yelling, having narcissistic or emotionally abusive parents, living through a tragedy or being bullied, those are also experiences that can make you find an escape through daydreaming. You know, how many of us have been in those circumstances when you are being bullied as a kid or your parents are yelling at each other or they're dealing with like financial problems and the only place that you can go that is your own is your mind. So daydreaming, it does become an escape. And I want to talk about that a little bit more, while we find ourselves so invested in these visions and our
或者作为一个经常不在家的父母身边的孩子，父母工作很忙，身处一个充满冲突和争论的家庭中的孩子，有自恋或情感虐待倾向的父母，经历过悲剧或被欺凌，这些也都是能让你通过白日梦寻找逃避出口的经历。你知道，我们有多少人在这种环境下长大：当你小时候被欺凌，或者你的父母在互相争吵，或者他们正在应对经济问题，而你唯一能去的属于你自己的地方就是你的大脑。所以白日梦确实成了一种逃避。在这段短暂的休息之后，我想更多地谈谈为什么我们在这些愿景中投入如此之深以及我们的
imagination after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental topics. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will
想象力。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神主题的科学。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会
come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at a podcast.
迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“T-W-A（TWO）percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金有什么狗屁关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam J. Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. So, you're finishing that sentence.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）、亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的。包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的快克（crack）毒品。澄清一下，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅是因为快克。我很乐意在任何一天谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看出一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。所以，你快把那句话说完吧。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的个人经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、莱恩·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you here on earth?
有时我们在追求某事物的过程中，过于执着于追逐，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了该事物。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于赢与输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要吗？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose
你是一个好人，因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，我们一起进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话，
on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
尽在我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hardway）并立即收听。2023年前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这开启了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你伪造了这个特定测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。互联网侦探大军花了很长时间才破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg Lespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Lespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The most prominent explanation in like the psychological community for why Maladap of daydreaming occurs is that it is a form of escapism like we've alluded to. Escapism basically means finding a way to distract ourselves from real life problems deliberately or by accident and either just for a moment when things get stressful temporarily or for a prolonged period of time. It's a really incredible survival instinct to survival urge in our brain that is basically like, okay, there is nothing more I can do, but I can maybe minimize the trauma of this experience if I just completely clock out, if I just leave this
在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。心理学界对适应不良性白日梦发生原因最突出的解释是，它正如我们所暗示的那样，是一种逃避现实的形式。逃避现实基本上意味着有意或无意地寻找方法将自己从现实生活的问题中分散注意力，无论是在事情变得紧张时只是暂时的一会儿，还是持续很长一段时间。这是我们大脑中一种非常惊人的生存本能、生存冲动，它基本上在说：好吧，我无能为力了，但如果我彻底“下线”，如果我把这一切抛在脑后，我或许能把这次经历的创伤减到最小。
behind. All of us, I think, do need that kind of escape sometimes from what's going on around us. That's actually perfectly natural. It's hardwired into our minds. But it's not meant to last forever. It's meant to temporarily, you know, prevent us from being emotionally and cognitively overloaded, kind of like blowing off of steam and, you know, when you get home from work, putting on music or switching off in front of the TV, those are other forms of like that kind of mental escapism or mental switch off that is important for our brain. But excessive escapism of any kind, whether it is getting incredibly invested in video games or social media or shopping, or substance use, it becomes a problem when we rely on this habit to regulate our emotional lives
我认为我们所有人都确实需要这种对周围发生事情的逃避。这实际上是完全自然的。它深深植根于我们的脑海中。但它并不意味着永远持续下去。它旨在暂时地，你知道，防止我们在情感和认知上超载，有点像释放压力，你知道的，当你下班回家时，听听音乐或在电视机前放空，那些是这种精神逃避或精神放空的另外几种形式，对我们的大脑很重要。但任何形式的过度逃避——无论是极其投入到电子视频游戏、社交媒体、购物，还是药物使用——当我们需要依靠这种习惯来调节我们的情感生活时，就会成为一个问题。
and that's our only skill. You know, we don't feel okay without it. It's our only way to cope. And it's getting in the way of everyday life. I read this one person's really compelling story on Reddit, actually, that I wanted to share to explain why maladaptive daydreaming is kind of up there with a lot of other forms of escapism and how complex it is. I've actually been doing a lot of deep diving into Reddit recently when I'm researching things for the show because there are just like so many communities of people online. And there are communities for every single issue or problem you can think of and people are so vulnerable and open, but it's anonymous and they give each other advice. It's like being a fly on the wall for these like deeply personal 12 hour online discussions and just getting to observe. And
而这成了我们唯一的技能。你知道，没有它我们就觉得不正常。这是我们唯一的应对方式。而且它正在妨碍我们的日常生活。实际上，我在红迪网（Reddit）上读过一个人的非常引人入胜的故事，我想分享它来解释为什么适应不良性白日梦与许多其他形式的逃避现实并驾齐驱，以及它是多么复杂。我最近在为节目做研究时，实际上一直在Reddit上进行大量深入挖掘，因为网上有太多的人群社区。你可以想到的每一个问题或麻烦都有对应的社区，人们非常脆弱和开放，但又是匿名的，他们互相给予建议。这就像是在这些极其私人的长达12小时的在线讨论中做一个隐形旁观者并进行观察。而且
when I went searching for people's personal experiences with maladaptive daydreaming, I found this support group that had like 120,000 members. And this one person's testimony, which they had only posted maybe like a day before it really stood out. I don't feel like I belong in this world, so I created my own. At this point, my paracosom, which is basically a fancy word for imaginary world, my paracosum feels more real than my actual life. I don't escape into my daydreams. That is my home.
当我搜索人们对适应不良性白日梦的个人经历时，我找到了这个支持小组，它拥有大约12万名成员。其中一个人的证词在他们发布后大概一天左右就格外醒目。我觉得我不属于这个世界，所以我创造了自己的世界。此时此刻，“平行宇宙”（paracosm）——这基本上是想象世界的花哨说法——我的平行宇宙感觉比我的实际生活更真实。我不是逃进我的白日梦里。那是我的家。
What other people call real life is just a place that I visit from time to time. This is an extreme example of excessive escapism that has probably come from a really prolonged habit of maladaptive daydreaming. But what it really articulates for me is that those of us who daydream quite excessively, there is a definite split between imaginary world and the real world. and this person is basically saying, like, I'm choosing to stay in the imaginary world because it's safer. Normally, this really intricate, you know, internal life, it has been developed because there's something about our real life that we want to avoid. But, you know, unlike escapism through physical external activities like gambling or impulse spending or drugs or video games,
别人所说的现实生活只是我偶尔去参观一下的地方。这是过度逃避现实的一个极端例子，它可能来自适应不良性白日梦的长期习惯。但对我真正阐明的是，我们这些白日梦做得相当过头的人，想象中的世界和现实世界之间存在着明确的裂痕。这个人基本上是在说：我选择留在想象的世界里，因为那里更安全。通常，这种极其复杂的内在生活之所以发展起来，是因为我们的现实生活中有某种我们想要避免的东西。但是，你知道，与通过赌博、冲动消费、毒品或电子游戏等物理外部活动的逃避不同，
from the outside, no one would know. Like there's no obvious warning signs of excessive maladaptive daydreaming because by nature, like, it's so private. And so I think there is a lot of people who get away with this being a real advice for them and no one really being able to tell because there's no symptoms. There was a 22 study conducted in Finland that also found that there is quite a strong correlation between how bad we think things are going in the world and how often we find us. themselves mentally escaping through these distractions. And as our stress levels rise, as did the hours spent daydreaming by participants. Another correlation by two researchers in India back in 2021, it found that people who are lonely, they spend more hours maladaptive day dreaming. Between like four to seven hours a day was their estimate. That's like more than my screen time for the day,
从外部来看，没有人会知道。就像没有过度适应不良性白日梦的明显警告信号，因为从本质上讲，它是如此私密。所以我认为有很多人让这种情况作为他们真正的庇护所而逃脱了惩罚，没有人真正能够看出来，因为没有症状。2022年在芬兰进行的一项研究还发现，我们认为世界上事情变糟的程度与我们经常发现自己通过这些分心事物在精神上逃避的频率之间存在着相当强的相关性。随着我们压力水平的上升，参与者做白日梦的小时数也在增加。印度两位研究人员在2021年的另一项相关性研究发现，感到孤独的人会花更多的小时进行适应不良性白日梦。他们的估计是每天大约4到7小时。这比我一天的屏幕使用时间还要多，
in my own thoughts, being quite disconnected. And it makes sense. to me why now and in the last 10 years, rates of daydreaming and other forms of escapism have really increased and become such a buzz topic because a lot of us in this younger generation, we are more pessimistic than ever, we are lonelier than ever, the real world feels very gloomy, but fantasy can be whatever we want it to be. Our dreams can be whatever we want them to be, and they really do feel quite real. There is also, I'm going to say, like, quite an important relationship between maladaptive daydreaming and anxiety because it can be so soothing in the moment when everything around us feels stressful and is really heightened and
沉浸在自己的思想中，相当脱节。对我来说，为什么现在以及在过去的10年里，白日梦和其他形式的逃避现实的比率真正增加了并成为一个热门话题，这是说得通的，因为我们这代年轻人中的许多人比以往任何时候都更加悲观，比以往任何时候都更加孤独，现实世界感觉非常阴暗，但幻想可以是我们想要的任何样子。我们的梦想可以是我们想要的任何样子，它们确实感觉相当真实。我也要说，适应不良性白日梦与焦虑之间存在着相当重要的关系，因为当周围的一切都让人感到压力重重、高度紧张和
intense. You know, maladaptive daydreaming is like this place where we can go to retreat. But there's also a component of it that is emotional avoidance, you know. if we can always just retreat to this place in our mind and we use this unconscious protective mechanism, it means that we never actually confront what it is about our environment, our circumstances, our real life that is so upsetting. The most significant link as well is it's not to do with anxiety, it's not to do with escapism, it's actually interestingly to do with OCD.
激烈时，它在当时可以起到非常舒缓的作用。你知道，适应不良性白日梦就像是我们去退守的地方。但它也有情感回避的一个组成部分，你知道的。如果我们总是能退守到我们大脑中的这个地方，并且我们使用了这种无意识的保护机制，这就意味着我们永远不会真正去面对环境中、我们的处境中、我们的现实生活中究竟是什么让我们如此不安。最显着的联系也是，它与焦虑无关，与逃避现实无关，有趣的是，它实际上与强迫症（OCD）有关。
And we haven't even mentioned it yet despite being like, if you look at the literature on maladaptive daydreaming, so much of it comes back to OCD. So OCD for a refresher is a condition that features like recurring, unwanted thoughts, ideas, or obsessions that you can't switch off. You know, one of my biggest pet peeves is when people are like, oh, you know, OCD is basically just like wanting things to be neat or like germophobia or being quite type A. You know, that is such a misconception it leads to so many people being misunderstood. You know, OCD is really about trying to control unwanted, intrusive thoughts that make us feel intense stress and anxiety. And the only way that we feel we can lessen that anxiety is by these repetitive behaviors. If we think
我们甚至都还没提到它，尽管如果你看看关于适应不良性白日梦的文献，就会发现很多都指向强迫症（OCD）。强迫症简单来说是一种以反复出现的、不想要的思想、想法或强迫观念为特征的状况，这些想法是你无法摆脱的。你知道，我最讨厌的事情之一就是人们觉得，哦，你知道，强迫症基本上就是想要东西整洁，或者是洁癖，再或者是A型性格。你知道，这真的是一个巨大的误解，导致很多人被误解。你知道，强迫症其实是关于试图控制那些不想要的、强迫性的想法，这些想法会让我们感到强烈的压力和焦虑。而我们唯一能减轻这种焦虑的方法就是通过这些重复的行为。如果我们思考
about that in the case of maladaptive daydreaming, something in our life is really unpleasant, uncomfortable. That is the trigger. It's not as we want. And it's bringing up a lot of really anxious thoughts that we don't want to confront. But they just keep coming into our brain. We can't control this. We can't control this. This is happening. And so we have this compulsion, this compulsion towards our daydreaming that alleviates the stress and the pain. There is a really strong body of evidence that between 30 to 50% of people with O'Ss, also report experiencing prolonged daydreaming. And a person with OCD might engage in this because it is literally the only time when they don't feel fearful or anxious when they're in this state.
在适应不良性白日梦的情况下，我们生活中的某些事情真的很不愉快、很不舒服。这就是导火索。这并不是我们想要的。它引发了许多我们不想面对的焦虑想法。但它们却不断涌入我们的大脑。我们无法控制这一点。我们无法控制。这种情况正在发生。所以我们有这种强迫冲动，一种对白日梦的强迫冲动，这可以减轻压力和痛苦。有非常强有力的证据表明，30%到50%的强迫症患者也报告经历过长时间的白日梦。患有强迫症的人可能会沉浸其中，因为这简直是他们在这种状态下唯一不会感到恐惧或焦虑的时刻。
One group of researchers in Germany, they recruited 77 people who reported daydreaming excessively and they asked them to keep a daily diary for just two weeks. and they wanted them to basically be like, how often do you find yourself daydreaming? And then how's your mood? How are your like mental health symptoms? Specifically like looking at depression, anxiety and OCD. And it was found that when participants handed back these kind of like diaries, these journals,
德国的一组研究人员招募了77名报告有过度白日梦现象的人，他们要求这些人只记录两周的日常日记。他们基本上是想了解：你发现自己陷入白日梦的频率是多少？然后你的情绪怎么样？你的心理健康症状怎么样？特别关注抑郁、焦虑和强迫症。结果发现，当参与者交回这些日记、这些日志时，
when they were engaging in daydreaming, when it was becoming more frequent for them, their mood actually became worse. They felt more annoyed. more frustrated, they felt more anxious, and they also experienced significantly more OCD symptoms because there was a cycle. There was a cycle between maladaptive daydreaming and an initial, you know, soothing, calming sensation, some fun, maybe some entertainment, but actually a long-term avoidance and a long-term contribution to a worsening problem.
当他们沉迷于白日梦、白日梦变得更加频繁时，他们的情绪实际上变得更糟了。他们感到更加恼火、更加沮丧、更加焦虑，而且他们还经历了明显更多的强迫症症状，因为这是一个循环。适应不良性白日梦与最初的、你知道的抚慰、平静的感觉、一些乐趣、也许还有一些娱乐之间存在一个循环，但实际上这是一种长期的逃避，并且长期来看会使问题恶化。
Here is what that cycle looked like. We experience a negative emotion or a negative thought, which makes us daydream more, which in turn makes us feel worse, which makes us more disconnected from reality and our daily experiences, which is, you know, makes us more likely to daydream, which makes us feel worse again. So there is this whole cycle. Every time something bad confronts you and you're like, okay, this is just too much. This assignment is too much. This assignment is too much. This friendship is too much. I don't want to think about my relationship failing. I'm just going to like settle in for a daydream. Maybe not even thinking about it. The cycle and the initial feelings just become bigger. I know this is all sounding really, really serious. I haven't
这个循环是这样的：我们经历负面情绪或负面想法，这让我们做更多的白日梦，这反过来让我们感觉更糟糕，这让我们更加脱离现实和日常生活体验，你知道，这让我们更有可能做白日梦，这又让我们感觉更糟糕。所以这就是整个循环。每当有什么糟糕的事情发生，你心想，好吧，这实在太难了。这个任务太难了。这个任务太难了。这段友谊太重了。我不想去想我的关系破裂。我只想找个白日梦躲进去。也许甚至不去想它。这个循环和最初的感觉只会变得越来越大。我知道这听起来真的很严重。我刚刚
quite heavy there for a second. But again, like not all daydreaming is bad for you. Nick, we're not going to make huge generalizations here that every instance of having a nice thought, thinking about Christmas with your family, thinking about your wedding, thinking about graduating, like, you're suddenly mentally unwell. You know, it's an important part of how our mind protects itself and it's actually probably what makes us very human being able to fantasize and being able to dream. So please don't apply a deeper meaning. Like it's not always a sign of mental illness. It's not always a sign of escapism. Sometimes it is just how we cope. And there is actually suggestions that daydreaming, when it's at a healthy level, can help us reach Govs faster
稍微沉重了一会儿。但话说回来，并不是所有的白日梦对你都有害。尼克，我们不会在这里做一个巨大的概括，即每一次产生美好的想法、想象和家人过圣诞节、想象你的婚礼、想象毕业，都突然代表你精神不健康了。你知道，这是我们心灵自我保护的重要组成部分，能够幻想和梦想可能正是让我们如此具人性特质的原因。所以请不要赋予它更深层的意义。这并不总是精神疾病的迹象。这并不总是逃避现实的迹象。有时它只是我们的应对方式。事实上，有观点认为，处于健康水平的白日梦可以帮助我们更快地达成目标，
because it is a form of motivation. When you have a really super clear idea of what you want in the future and what that feels like and looks like and all the sensations associated with it, and when you think about that quite regularly, it can really inspire you and line of fire to work harder. It's actually like a whole motivational self-improvement strategy called visualization, which we've talked about before. You know, that is a healthier version of daydreaming, one that is incredibly powerful. And I want to talk about how we can turn out unhealthy,
因为它是一种动力的形式。当你对未来想要什么、那种感觉和外观是什么样以及与之相关的所有感觉有一个超级清晰的想法，并且当你相当定期地思考这些时，它真的可以激励你，并点燃你更加努力工作的斗志。这实际上就像是一种被称为视觉化的整体激励自我提升策略，我们以前讨论过。你知道，那是白日梦的一种更健康的版本，一种具有不可思议力量的版本。我想谈谈我们如何将不健康的、
excessive daydreaming into something that is future-orientated, into something that is useful, quite mentally powerful as well. So we are going to discuss all of that and more and how we can get our maladaptive daydreaming under control, After this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
过度的白日梦转变为面向未来的、有用的、并且在精神上也很有力量的事情。因此，在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容，以及如何控制我们的适应不良性白日梦。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the world. wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一边成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。这就是 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方的 T-W-O-Percent。
when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down,
戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上双击小金的胸部时？或者当侃爷说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在“回顾过去”播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的快克毒品。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意在某天谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把爱滋病摆在桌面上。
Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
然后你完成这句话。是的。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾过去”。欢迎来到我的新播客“艰难学习”，我是您的主持人、您最喜欢的治疗师，
Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我将带入我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候已经做够了。因为人们在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的只是做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客“艰难学习”中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序，搜索“学习艰难”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于 paternity 丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这开启了长达数年的法庭之争以证明真相。你曾两次篡改某个人的这项测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of.
格雷戈·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“爱情陷阱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在正义得到伸张之前，这一切还没有结束。
served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Turning maladaptive daydreaming into something helpful, like motivational visualization where we develop a mental image of what we want to achieve and how we imagine ourselves getting there, it really involves shifting our daydreaming from being escapist to being purposeful. And I want to really hammer that home from escapist.
在亚利桑那州服刑。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Love Trapped”播客。将适应不良性白日梦转变为有帮助的东西，比如激励性的可视化，我们在其中对想要实现的目标以及如何想象自己到达那里形成心理图像，这确实需要将我们的白日梦从逃避现实转变为有目的性。我想真正强调这一点：从逃避现实
to purposeful. Essentially, we want to get to a place where we aren't trying to run anymore or find a break from reality. We actually want to take back control of our reality to make it a place we want to be, even if it is the harder decision. Some really interesting studies have found that when you intentionally spend time in your day visualizing the life that you want and the steps you're going to take to get there, rather than just having that unstructured date, dreaming. You do tend to make more progress. You feel more purposeful. Your actions are more in alignment with the final outcome you want because you are internally motivated by the possibility. It's actually called by some the power of the mind's eye, creating like a very vivid, detailed mental image
到有目的性。本质上，我们要达到这样一个境界：我们不再试图逃跑或寻找现实的休息。我们实际上想要重新掌控我们的现实，使其成为我们想要身处的地方，即使这是一个更艰难的决定。一些非常有趣的研究发现，当你有意花时间在一天中可视化你想要的生活以及你将采取的步骤来实现它，而不是仅仅进行那种非结构化的白日梦时。你确实往往会取得更多的进步。你会觉得更有目的性。你的行动更符合你想要的最终结果，因为你受到可能性的内在激励。这实际上被一些人称为“心眼的力量”，创造一个非常生动、详细的心理图像
of where you want to be as a way to clarify your desires and make more constructive progress, I guess. And I know it sounds very similar to daydreaming, but the big thing that we need to articulate here, the big difference is that visualization is deliberate, it's structured, it's realistic. So you're not fantasizing about marrying a celebrity, you're not fantasizing about saving a crashing plane, you're fantasizing about something or visualizing something that is possible. It's definitely not excessive as well. and it's used situationally to inspire. Daydreaming is unstructured.
关于你想去哪里，作为一种澄清你的愿望并取得更多建设性进展的方式，我猜。我知道这听觉上与白日梦非常相似，但我们需要在这里阐明的大事、巨大的区别在于，可视化是刻意的、结构化的、现实的。所以你不是在幻想嫁给名人，你不是在幻想拯救一架坠毁的飞机，你是在幻想某事或可视化某种可能的事情。它绝对也不是过度的，并且在情境中被用来激发灵感。而白日梦是非结构化的。
It takes up a lot of time. It's very outlandish. And it's more distraction than intention. And I think the really good thing about visualization and in its kind of treatment of maladaptive daydreaming is that you don't have to give it all up, right? It's like supplementary. It's like a replacement therapy that is healthier.
这会占用大量时间，而且很不切实际。这带来的更多是分心而非意图。我觉得，关于可视化以及它对非适应性白日梦的治疗，真正好的一点在于，你不需要完全戒掉它，对吧？它就像是一种补充。它就像是一种更健康的替代疗法。
I think moving away from maladaptive daydreaming can be a hard shift without that, because it does mean that you have to spend more time being present before we bring in that visualization. That is something that you have to confront, that you do have to see the parts of your life that might not necessarily be as positive or as enjoyable. It also means more time feeling our feelings, feeling uncomfortable, sad, disappointed, really listening and seeing what's going on around us. But you have to stick with it.
我认为，在没有这种替代的情况下，摆脱非适应性白日梦可能会是一个艰难的转变，因为这意味着在引入可视化之前，你必须花更多的时间活在当下。这是你必须面对的事情，你必须看到自己生活中不一定那么积极或令人愉快的部分。这也意味着要花更多时间去感受我们的情绪，去感受不舒服、悲伤、失望，真正去倾听和观察我们周围正在发生的事情。但你必须坚持下去。
You have to, like, it's acceptance. There is a real acceptance to this. That life is not perfect. It is not a fantasy. But you still have to be there for it because that's what makes it so sweet. You know, the imperfections, the roller coaster. And when you've spent a lot of time avoiding that, it can be really, really hard, but people do it.
你必须——这就叫做接受。对这一点必须有真正的接受。生活并不完美，它不是幻想。但你依然必须去面对它，因为正是这些才让生活如此美好。你知道的，那些不完美，那些过山车般的经历。当你花了很多时间去逃避这些时，这可能会非常非常困难，但人们确实做到了。
People do it all the time. So what we want to do is really recognize triggers and, patterns, identify when, where, why you start maladaptive daydreaming. Is it when you're in a certain environment around certain people? After seeing certain people, is it at the end of a hard day? Is it at your job? Is it when you're alone and feeling lonely? I think, and I believe really deeply, that maladaptive daydreaming is not unprompted.
人们一直在这样做。所以我们想要做的是，真正去识别触发因素和模式，找出你何时、何地、为何开始陷入非适应性白日梦。是因为你身处某个特定环境，周围有特定的人吗？是在见过某些人之后吗？是在艰难的一天结束时吗？是在你的工作岗位上吗？是当你独自一人感到孤独的时候吗？我想，而且我深信，非适应性白日梦绝不是毫无缘由的。
It might feel like it comes along spontaneously, like suddenly we're daydreaming. But actually, there's normally a feeling at the root of it. There's normally stress, boredom, disappointment, loneliness that is causing us to find this safety and sanctuary. Once you know that, I think that that's the first step. I think then you're able to find alternatives to being in those situations. You are able to really consciously, deliberately think, if this is, if my reality, if my life is creating this urge to not even be present in my life.
它可能感觉像是自发出现的，就像我们突然开始白日梦一样。但实际上，它的根源通常都有一种情绪。通常是压力、无聊、失望或孤独，正是这些导致我们去寻找这种安全感和避难所。一旦你明白了这一点，我认为这就是第一步。然后你就能找到替代方案来应对那些情境。你能够真正有意识、深思熟虑地去思考：如果这——如果我的现实、我的生活正在产生这种甚至不想活在当下生活中的冲动……
life, to escape my life, is it really what I want? And that is the shift that I want us to grab onto. The possibility that you can change your life, you can do something about it rather than just, you know, daydreaming about doing so or escaping. And this is where we can transition our daydreams towards visualization. What this involves it is consciously assessing your daydreams for what could happen, what is basically possible versus impossible and trying to focus more. on what is real. You know, I think we mentioned it before, being more realistic about what you're thinking about. Visualize really purposefully.
想要逃离我的生活，这真的是我想要的吗？这就是我想让我们抓住的转变。你可以改变生活，你可以为此做些什么，而不是仅仅（你知道的）空想去这样做或是逃避。这就是我们可以将白日梦转变为可视化的地方。这涉及有意识地评估你的白日梦：什么可能会发生，什么是可能的与不可能的，并努力更多地关注真实的事情。你知道，我想我们之前提到过，对你所思考的事情要更加现实。要有针对性地进行可视化。
Instead of like fantasizing aimlessly, I want you to channel all that energy and all the investment that you have in your daydreams to daydreaming about the goals that you really want to achieve, that you know that you can that are possible. Picture achieving things like personal milestones, like career success, small wins. what will that feel like? Will you feel proud, excited, peaceful, loved? Put all the energy into a realistic vision of your future. Visualization is also action-oriented thinking rather than only daydreaming about the end result, this big, bright, flashy future. Visualize and fall in love with the process. Imagine yourself taking steps towards your goals, overcoming challenges, persisting through setbacks,
与其漫无目的地幻想，我希望你将所有的能量和投入到白日梦中的精力，引导到去梦想你真正想要实现的目标，那些你知道自己能够做到、是切实可行的目标。想象自己实现各种事情，比如个人里程碑、职业成功、小小的胜利。那会是什么感觉？你会感到骄傲、兴奋、平静、被爱吗？把所有的能量投入到对未来的现实愿景中。可视化也是一种以行动为导向的思考，而不是仅仅梦想着最终的结果——那个宏大、耀眼、闪烁的未来。去可视化并爱上这个过程。想象自己朝着目标迈出步伐，克服挑战，在挫折中坚持不懈，
and you can kind of use your daydreams, use this like mental blackboard to rehearse your next steps. And that really helps you like clarify your path, consider possibilities, consider different strategies and build confidence, this mental confidence that, you know, if I can think it, I can do it. I've rehearsed this. I've thought about this. These are my next steps. All of my mental energy is going towards bringing about this reality. that's like the whole basis for manifestation right you know it sounds very similar because it basically is it's essentially a version of this practice that is a bit more scientific we're going to combine that focused intention with the positive thinking with the visualization that creates action that creates a
你可以利用你的白日梦，利用这个“心理黑板”来排练你的下一步行动。这真的能帮理清你的道路，思考各种可能性，考虑不同的策略，并建立自信——这种心理自信，让你知道：“如果我能想到，我就能做到。我已经排练过了。我已经想过这件事了。这些就是我的下一步行动。”我所有的心理能量都用在了将这种现实变为现实上。这其实就是吸引力法则的全部基础，对吧？你懂的，听起来很相似，因为它基本上就是。本质上，这就是这种实践的一个更具科学性的版本，我们将这种专注的意图与积极的思考相结合，与可视化相结合，从而创造行动，创造一个
self-fulfilling prophecy whereby the more we think about something and believe that it could come true the more confidence we have in taking actions that will make it true, in confirming our expectations because we are already kind of seeing success rather than failure. You know, it's quite spiritual, but we can also make it quite actionable. After you have those moments of intentional visualization, I want you to finish and finish with an action that you can take now. Every time you are fantasizing, thinking, dreaming, imagining, this few, future, when you're done, what is one thing you can do in the next 10 minutes that could actually
自我实现的预言：我们对某事想得越多，并且越相信它会成真，我们就越有信心采取行动让它成真，从而证实我们的期望，因为我们已经在某种程度上看到了成功而不是失败。你知道，这其实挺精神层面的，但我们也可以让它变得非常具有可操作性。在你进行那些有意识的可视化时刻之后，我希望你能以一个你现在就能采取的行动来结束。每次你幻想、思考、做梦、想象这个未来，当你结束后，在接下来的10分钟里，你能做的、实际上能帮到你的一件事是什么？
help you towards this thing that you are fantasizing about? No matter how minor, you know, if you've been visualizing about starting a business, your small step after you stop visualizing could be learning how to register a business, learning taxation law for the kind of business that you want, learning and just researching about manufacturers or supply chains, all those things. You know, I think that we have the nice feeling of being like, wow, this is exciting. This is something that's possible. I want that. We take that nice feeling and we put it into action and we use it as motivation to do.
无论它有多么微不足道，你知道的，如果你一直在可视化自己创业，那么在你停止可视化之后，你的小步骤可以是从学习如何注册公司开始，学习你想要开展的那类业务的税法，学习和研究制造商或供应链，所有这些事情。你知道的，我觉得我们有一种美好的感觉，觉得“哇，这太令人兴奋了。这是可能实现的。我想要那个。”我们带着这种美好的感觉，把它付诸行动，并把它当作去做的动力。
And that ties your daydreaming or in this case, your visualization to real progress to something. you can see in front of you. Remind yourself, thinking about something is not doing, as much as it may feel that way. How much do you actually want the life that you are imagining? And can you afford to spend hours just fantasizing about it? Or is there something you could do with that time that would get you closer to that actual outcome? I also think that going back to what we said before about the links between.
这就把你的白日梦——或者在这个例子中，你的可视化——与真正的进展、与你能亲眼看到的东西联系在了一起。提醒自己：思考某事并不等于去做，尽管感觉上可能差不多。你到底有多渴望你想象中的那种生活？你真的负担得起花好几个小时去幻想它吗？或者，你本可以用这些时间去做点什么，能让你更接近那个实际的结果？我还认为，回到我们之前说的关于……的联系。
daydreaming and OCD and anxiety and trauma? Is that something that you really need to address? Is that really what could help you stop turning to this habit as a form of escapism? Is it something more mental, more psychological? I really think it's worth looking into it. It's worth finding a really great therapist who can assist you with that journey of discovery and that journey of shifting how you address and how you tackle stress and anxiety and really bad thoughts. You know, there's a really interesting article by Harvard Medical School that I read as I was researching this topic.
白日梦与强迫症、焦虑和创伤之间的联系？这是你真正需要解决的问题吗？这真的是能帮你不把这种习惯当作逃避现实的手段的关键吗？这是更偏向心理层面的、更深层次的事情吗？我真的觉得这很值得去了解。找一位真正优秀的心理治疗师来协助你完成这段探索之旅，以及改变你应对和处理压力、焦虑和消极想法的方式，这是非常值得的。你知道，我在研究这个话题时读到过哈佛医学院一篇非常有趣的文章。
And they say there is no single treatment for maladaptive daydreaming because it is so private and individual, but you have to find what works for you. That could be treating daydreaming like meditation that you do once a day. you only do it in a specific location or at a specific time like in the shower or on the train and then every other time you have to actively stop for some people it's keeping busy find what works for you maybe it is visualization you can't quite let go of the habit but at least you can make it something that helps you rather than distracts you you can make it something that is intentional and inspiring and motivating this was such an informative episode for me to even do
他们说，对于非适应性白日梦并没有单一的治疗方法，因为它是如此私密和个性化，但你必须找到适合你自己的方法。那可能是把白日梦当作一种每天做一次的冥想，你只在特定的地点或特定的时间进行，比如在淋浴时或在火车上，而在其他所有时间你都必须积极地制止它；对有些人来说，则是让自己保持忙碌。找到适合你的方法。也许是可视化——你可能无法完全戒掉这个习惯，但至少你可以让它变成一件对你有帮助、而不是让你分心的事情，你可以让它成为一件有意图、有启发性、有动力的事情。对我自己来说，做这期节目也是一次信息量极大的经历……
with some of my prior knowledge and some of the new knowledge that I picked up, I want to thank the person. And there were multiple people actually who messaged me to do this episode. Thank you. I've learned so much. I feel so enlightened. And it's crazy how you look at these things and you're like, oh, yeah, maladaptive daydreaming. Like, I just like to daydream a lot. And when you start diving into the research and the science, it's so much more complex and nuanced and emotional and personal. So if you're struggling with this, I'll leave some resources in the description, including that measure and that method for assessing yourself and that consultatorium of people who are doing some really cool research into this.
结合我之前的一些知识以及我新学到的知识，我要感谢这个人。实际上有不止一个人发信息让我做这期节目。谢谢你们。我学到了很多。我觉得自己深受启发。而当你审视这些事情并心想：“哦，对啊，非适应性白日梦。我只是喜欢做做白日梦罢了，”然后当你开始深入研究研究和科学时，你会发现它要复杂得多、微妙得多、也更具情感色彩和个人色彩。所以，如果你正在与此挣扎，我会在简介中留下一些资源，包括那个用于自我评估的量表和方法，以及那个汇聚了正在对此进行非常酷的研究的人们的咨询群落。
You can also DM me on Instagram with your own stories. I want to hear more about what this experience is like for you. We also, of course, take episode suggestions. And if you did enjoy this episode, make sure to leave us a five-star review. Follow along on Spotify on Apple Podcasts. And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. and we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all?
你也可以在Instagram上给我发私信，分享你自己的故事。我想听听更多关于你对这段经历的感受。当然，我们也接受节目建议。如果你确实喜欢这期节目，请务必给我们留下五星好评，在Spotify和Apple Podcasts上关注我们。直到下期节目再见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些，我们很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Keer Games）带来的《艰难学习法》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间专门探讨黑男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都实在不够安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一身盔甲？它向世界释放的信号是：你可惹不起我。仅仅因为你有这种能力，
that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习法》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控使人怀上双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的检测结果两……两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测结果。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人……
Greg Gillespie and Michael Mianini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
格雷格·吉利斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·米亚尼尼（Michael Mianini）。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his
这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即“TWO percent”，在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个高产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的
last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《相信闺蜜，相信我吧，宝贝》（Trust Me, Babe），在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一档IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。